[Musique]
bienvenue je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de paris saclay
tv comment convaincre les entreprises de
rejoindre votre territoire de rejoindre
cet écosystème unique en son genre en
france eh bien c'est la raison d'être de
la sat paris saclay ça pour sociétés
d'accélération du transfert de
technologies en collaboration avec le
pea paris saclay fait ça tu as mené une
étude très fouillée sur la filière
intelligence artificielle
combien de start up de grands groupes de
laboratoires
d'entreprises travaillent dans ce
domaine
eh bien vous saurez tout grâce à une
cartographie très précise et vous saurez
aussi beaucoup de choses grâce à ce show
room technologique alors si il y à plus
d'une centaine de start-up installés sur
le territoire qui s'intéressent à
l'intelligence artificielle il y a aussi
des gros groupes comme ibm ibm qui a
choisi d'installer ici son tout nouveau
centre de recherche et de développement
dédiée à l'intelligence artificielle qui
voudrait qu'il ya déjà des synergies qui
sont mises en place une délégation
québécoise quantique est venu sur votre
territoire elle a été accueillie par le
groupe atos et là aussi il s'agit donc
de développer des partenariats de faire
découvrir d'autres écosystèmes même
stratégie même volonté pour kimia lice
alors cette start up elle a été lauréate
du sprint 50 cette année dans la
catégorie santé et si elle a choisi
paris saclay c'est parce qu'elle est
liée avec l'école normale supérieure
vous entendrez son ceo cyril gibert et
enfin notre agenda ce sera la fin de
cette émission
faut-il le rappeler l'écosystème de
paris saclay est unique en son genre
pour développer se clôt ce top pour le
faire connaître il existe de nombreux
levier la sat la société d'accélération
du transfert de technologie a pour but
de mieux faire connaître aux entreprises
donc paris saclay votre territoire en
collaboration avec le pea paris saclay
sept sacs paris saclay a mené une étude
très fouillée sur la filière
intelligence artificielle
d'intelligence artificielle que l'on
peut retrouver grâce à une cartographie
très précise de votre territoire la sat
a aussi mis en place ce showroom
technologique
[Musique]
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui dans le
cas de la restitution de l'étude filière
ya que nous réalisons dans le cas de
notre activité de développement
économique est le père paris saclay nous
avons monté pour cela la satel aspect
d'accélération de transfert de
technologie qui a une très bonne
connaissance des acteurs du territoire
et une vision aussi à 300° des
différents laboratoires publics qui le
composent au delà de l'objectif de mieux
se connaître l'enjeu c'est également
d'utiliser tout ce contenu pour mieux
promouvoir l'éco cette année paris
saclay notamment dans les actions que
nous réalisons à l'international lors de
participation à des salons
professionnels
l'objectif principal c'est vraiment de
convaincre les entreprises de venir
rejoindre écosystèmes
[Musique]
dans cette cartographie à paris saclay
nous avons répertorié l'ensemble des
entreprises sur paris saclay qui
travaille avec des chercheurs qui
produisent des retrouvailles de
recherche en y a nous avons trouvé 110
start up créée depuis 2010 sur ces
thématiques et enfin 80 à 90 entreprises
pme des grands groupes qui travaillent
fortement avec paris saclay sur ces
thématiques ja nous avons aussi recensé
42 laboratoire de recherche d'un très
haut niveau académique qui travaillent
sur l'ia sur plusieurs thématiques de ia
qui sont fédérés sur deux blocs qui sont
à y parisse plutôt pour ip pays
l'institut polytechnique de paris et
ensuite data ya plutôt pour l'université
paris saclay et inria et enfin et pour
conclure en termes d'indicateurs paris
saclay abrite 17 % des laboratoires
nationaux qui travaillent sur
l'intelligence artificielle mais 41% des
stars chercheurs entrepreneurs
confondues qui font l'intelligence
artificielle et un autre chiffre très
important c'est que dans l'appel à
projets de la nr sur les chairs en
intelligence artificielle paris saclay a
remporté 16 des 40 projets ce qui
correspond à 40 % des projets actuels
entre industriels recherche fondamentale
sur l'intelligence artificielle donc pas
forcément beaucoup de laboratoires
beaucoup de laboratoires au niveau
national travaille sur l'ia mais une
qualité importante de la recherche qui
transparaît à travers ses chiffres enfin
la sat met en place d'autres actions
d'attractivité du territoire typiquement
avec le showroom technologique qui se
visite
[Musique]
une porte d'entrée dans notre beau
territoire d'excellence académique et
industriel le showroom technologique
mutualisé de la seine paris saclay du
playground est un outil marketing par
excellence qui présente la structuration
du territoire la complexité des échanges
entre ces acteurs les filières présentes
sur le territoire et oh bien sûr les
technologies de pointe à travers notre
exposition des start-up l'avantagé la
singularité de notre showroom c'est
d'être vraiment en showroom transverses
qui est une porte d'entrée sur le
territoire qui permet vraiment
rapidement comprendre les enjeux du
territoire paris saclay qui à travers
son exposition permet d'entrevoir
quelles sont les possibilités qui
s'offrent à des acteurs nationaux et
internationaux venant en visite sur le
territoire et travaillant dans les
laboratoires de recherche dans les lieux
d'excellence académique et industriel
dans les entreprises quel est l'intérêt
d'être présent sur ce territoire nous
pouvons le voir à travers l'exposition
de notre chaudron technologique
mutualisés
[Musique]
parmi les grands groupes qui sont en
pointe dans la filière intelligence
artificielle il ay ay ay bm ibm qui a
décidé d'installer son centre de
recherche et de développement sur votre
territoire à terme ce sont près de 400
chercheurs et développeurs qui vont
travailler dans ce domaine plusieurs
projets sont déjà lancées notamment dans
le secteur de l'imagerie médicale
[Musique]
entité qui se trouve ici le plateau de
paris saclay est une entité du bm de
tête un centre de co-innovation et qui
regroupe dans un premier temps une
équipe de développement logiciel
une équipe de recherche est également
une équipe de consulting l'équipe de
recherche que nous avons ici travaillent
sur des systèmes auto apprenant que nous
lions à des systèmes de moteurs de
règles business et qui permettent
d'appréhender des sujets tout à fait
nouveau en iran et puis nous avons
l'équipe de conseil qui va accompagner
nos clients sur tous leurs initiatives
d'innovation
au sens large
en termes de recherche quand on est à
plusieurs dès qu'on échange avec
d'autres personnes on avance plus vite
c'est pour ça que nous retrouvons ici
dans ce site tous ces ingrédients qui
sont propices en toutes les personnes
qui souhaitent faire de l'innovation
nous avons ici un sourcing de cerveau
les écoles produisent des ingénieurs
avec un niveau reconnu mondialement qui
fait partie des meilleurs dans le monde
académique nous avons des labos de
recherche à la fois académique et
industriel dans ceux de paris saclay
avec qui nous échangeons régulièrement
ce que nous cherchons à développer tout
particulièrement ici à sac les cds
partenariat tripartite ce qu'on va
commencer à faire avec à la fois d'un
côté ses labos de recherche et des
industriels et d'autre part des
académiques et les ingénieurs qui se
trouvent aux chesneaux en recherche et
aujourd'hui les partenariats que nous
développons nous en sommes nous sommes
convaincus vont permettre de avancer
beaucoup plus vite en termes
d'innovation et de ce que nous pouvons
offrir à nos clients le plateau de paris
saclay offre aux entreprises comme nos
des interactions la grande valeur
ajoutée avec tout cet écosystème de la
boe de recherche c'est pour ça que ce
site est un lieu incontournable pour
toutes les entreprises françaises ou
internationales qui souhaitent se
retrouver dans le creuset
d'innovation technologique et de et de
recherche qui est aujourd'hui un élément
essentiel notamment dans l'intelligence
artificielle
après l intelligence artificielle
intéressons nous maintenant à une autre
filière un autre domaine le cantique le
groupe atos qui est présent sur votre
territoire s'est lancé dans cette
aventure très pointu est là aussi pour
développer ces technologies du futur il
faut développer des partenariats
nationaux ou internationaux
atos a accueilli très récemment une
délégation quantique québécoise peut
être le début d'une collaboration outre
atlantique tout de suite les précisions
de philippe duluc directeur big data et
sécurité chez atos et olivier gagnon
gordillo responsable de la stratégie et
du développement québec quantique
nous avons le grand plaisir et l'honneur
d'accueillir aujourd'hui sur le site des
clayes-sous-bois d'atos principal site
de r&d en france d'atos une délégation
québécoise complètement centrée sur les
technologies quantiques donc des
investisseurs des start up et des
membres des clusters québécois non ça
c'est très important pour atos d'avoir
cette capacité de rencontrer des
écosystèmes étrangers en quantum puisque
atos a commencé à développer une
stratégie quantique de please années
2016 développé un simulateur un
simulateur quantique se prépare à
développer un supercalculateur hybride
quantique et dans ce cadre là nous
recherchons des partenaires et nous
voulons également participer à la grande
aventure du cantique c'est en fait une
véritable industrie qui est en train de
se développer donc ces écosystèmes sont
très précieux à nos yeux et nous permet
de développer des partenariats et
d'acquérir une connaissance de beaucoup
plus fine de ce qui se fait dans le
monde dans les technologies quantiques
[Musique]
thierry quantique telle initiative qui
regroupe l'écosystème des sciences et
technologies quantiques du québec l'idée
derrière la mission est pourquoi on est
ici aujourd'hui pour en fait créer des
collaborations et même amplifié ce qui a
déjà été fait par le passé on a déjà eu
quelques collaborations avec la france
en termes de science et technologie
quantique on est très heureux d'être ici
aujourd'hui pour visiter finalement
l'écosystème de paris saclay en passant
par atos et on a visité les laboratoires
de ses 2 m qui en même temps le profité
pour rencontrer quelques stades et
pendant plus de mariages avec des start
up du québec et des startups françaises
[Musique]
cet échange entre atos et cette
délégation québécoise est un exemple
parmi d'autres de ce qui se joue dans
l'écosystème paris saclay les start up
ne s'y trompe pas elle espère gagner en
visibilité en s'installant ici sur votre
territoire et c'est bien parti pour
qu'ils n'y alice cette start up a
remporté le concours spring 50 dans la
catégorie santé elle travaille en
collaboration étroite avec le n s paris
saclay l'école normale supérieure nous
avons rencontré son sillon cyril gilbert
[Musique]
je sais qu'ils me alice on développe
donc à marcianise un traitement chimique
innovant et breveté qui permet
d'améliorer la performance des tests
diagnostiques in vitro par exemple des
tests rapides tellement de l'être on a
tous utilisés durant l'accueil de 19 on
améliore la limite de détection de ces
tests cette technologie qu'on utilise
c'est un traitement chimique dont
breveté qui a été développé inventé par
mon associé claude noguès avec plus de
10 années de recherche au sein de la nes
cachant qui est maintenant le nes paris
saclay où est hébergée actuellement
keane alice
springs c'était un peu la mecque des
start up de paris-saclay donc l'occasion
de rencontrer d'autres start-up
innovantes dans le domaine de la santé
mais pas que la possibilité aussi long
pour rencontrer des industriels
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
développeurs de tester gnostique donc
toujours intéressant pour une start up
on est entrain de commercialiser notre
technologie on cherche aussi des
partenaires donc c'était pertinent de
rencontrer nos besoins industriels aussi
l'opportunité de rencontrer des
investisseurs
intéressant pour nous parce qu'on est en
train de lever un tour d'amorçage pour
financer la mise à l'échelle de notre
technologie
et puis c'était aussi gagner de la
visibilité ce qu'on a bien fait bien
réussi à faire en remportant le concours
de pitch dans le domaine santé avec des
très belles boîtes est également kitsch
et y avait de la concurrence et puis un
joli jury avec ipsen servier des fonds
d'investissement donc ça ça a permis
de gagner un peu en visibilité au niveau
national ce qui est le bienvenu dans une
période de levée de fonds et de début de
commercialisation
c'était naturel de s'installer à leur
jeunesse paris-saclay puisque encore une
fois la technologie et man 2 le n est
sonné juste à côté de l'ancien
laboratoire de claude donc ça il ya déjà
des synergies en termes de recherche et
de danse et technologique on a un
contrat de collaboration par exemple
avec le ls le cnrs aujourd'hui sur un
autre projet en interne
et puis c'est également le la
possibilité d'avoir en partage des
instruments qui sont trop onéreux pour
un achat en interne qui m'ya l'iss puis
évidemment l'accès à tout un vivier de
plateformes sur lesquelles on peut avoir
accès à ces instruments d'étudiants et
de personnes en thèse qui travaillent
sur des sujets d'intérêt pour qu'ils n'y
alice donc c'est finalement un peu un
point central même si on est éloigné de
paris centre c'est quand même un point
central dans le domaine dans lequel on
évolue avec tous les industriels qui
sont déjà
présents sur le plateau des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques des développeurs
d'outils d'analysé in vitro donc c'est
ça fait énormément sens d'être présent
ici sur le plateau
[Musique]
et maintenant notre agenda or c'est vous
propose de participer au festival du big
bang au big band troisième édition sur
site mais aussi en ligne au programme
des concerts des mini conférences des
ateliers des jeux pour les petits et
pour les grands c'est le 2 juillet de
14h à 18h vous avez envie de frissonner
de vivre un moment hors sol hors du
temps magique ne ratez pas la fine
ambühl tatiana mosuo bonga elle évolue
sur un fil à 20 mètres de haut pour une
traversée de son maître à haut risque au
dessus de la perspective de marta pan
l'une des oeuvres d'art public majeur de
saint quentin en yvelines ce sera le 10
juillet et enfin deux expositions pour
les curieux et les amoureux
d'architecturé la société du grand paris
et l'architecte dominique perrault
présente une exposition immersive sur le
plus grand projet urbain d'europe c'est
jusqu'au 13 juillet à l'espace réchaud
dans l'enfant de l'ancien hôpital royal
sous présenter des cartographies
historique du grand paris du réseau
ferré francilien et des quartiers des 68
future gare voilà de quoi préparer la
rentrée et enfin à l'exposition en
territoire en transformation imagine
l'espace public de demain en
s'intéressant aux mouvements de la terre
et à l'usagé qu'on en fait il y à un
focus sur le campus urbain avec le
projet de lisières vous avez jusqu'au 10
juillet pour découvrir cette exposition
c'est à versailles dans le futur
écoquartier de gally voilà c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite un très
bel été et je vous retrouve très vite
pour un numéro de paris saclay tv
[Musique]